Christopher Columbus is back in the
news. A few days ago on April 27, Donald
Trump said, quote, "I am bringing
Columbus Day back from the ashes. The
Democrats did everything possible to
destroy Christopher Columbus, his
reputation, and all of the Italians that
love him so much. They tore down his
statues and put up nothing but woke, or
even worse, nothing at all." Well,
you'll be happy to know Christopher is
going to make a major comeback. I am
hereby reinstating Columbus Day under
the same rules, dates, and locations as
it has had for all of the many decades
before. Trump is referring to the fact
that for years now, Columbus Day, also
increasingly known as Indigenous
People's Day, has been condemned as a
day when Americans celebrate the
genocidal actions of an Italian
psychopath and racist to boot who
savagely targeted the peaceful
Pocahontas-like natives of America.
Trump's point that the Democrats did
everything possible to destroy
Christopher Columbus is especially
validated by none other than his 2024
Democratic presidential candidate and
competitor Kala Harris. Not only is she
on record affirming that she wants to
officially cancel Columbus Day and
replace it with Indigenous People Day.
But in 2021 as vice president, she
condemned America's shameful past in the
context of Columbus. She said, quote,
"Since 1934, every October, the United
States has recognized the voyage of the
European explorers who first landed on
the shores of the Americas. Those
explorers ushered in a wave of
devastation for tribal nations,
perpetrating violence, stealing land,
and spreading disease. We must not shy
away from this shameful past, and we
must shed light on it and do everything
we can to address the impact of the past
on native communities today."
So good for Trump for caring about and
wanting to reinstate Columbus. Even
better, however, would be if we took
this occasion to remember why Columbus
sailed west in the first place. Although
the fake history we were all taught in
school claims Columbus and other
Europeans sailed west for spices or to
prove the world was round, the reality
is that they all did so first and
foremost to circumn and fight Muslims.
When Columbus was born, the then more
than 800year-old war with Islam, or
rather defense against jihad, was at an
all-time high. In 1453, when Columbus
was but 2 years old, the Turks finally
sacked Constantinople. An atrocity laid
an event that rocked Christendom to its
core. Over the following years, Muslims
continued making inroads deep into the
Balkans, leaving much death and
destruction in their wake, with millions
of Slavs enslaved. Yes, the two words
Slavs and slaves are etmologically
connected for this very reason. In 1480,
when Columbus was 29, the Turks even
managed to invade his native Italy. In
the city of Atronto, they ritually
beheaded 800 Italians and saw the local
archbishop in half for refusing to
recant Christianity and embrace Islam.
Their skulls are still housed invisible
to see at the Cathedral of Toronto. It
was in this backdrop that Spain's
monarchs Ferdinand and Isabella
themselves avowed crusaders especially
the queen who concluded the centuries
long reconista of Spain by liberating
Granada from Islam in 1492 took Columbus
into their service. They funded his
ambitious voyage in an effort to launch
in the words of historian Lewis Bertrand
quote a final and definite crusade
against Islam by way of the Indies which
culminated of course in the incidental
founding of the new world. Many
Europeans were convinced that if they
could only reach the peoples east of
Islam, who if not Christian, were at
least not as yet infected by the
Muhammadan plague, to quote Nicholas the
5th, who was Pope during Columbus'
youth. Together they could crush Islam
between them. The plan was centuries old
and connected to the legend of Prester
John, a supposedly great Christian
monarch reigning in the east who would
one day march westward and avenge
Christendom by destroying Islam. All
this comes out in Columbus's own
letters. In one, he refers to Ferdinand
and Isabella as quote enemies of the
wretched sect of Muhammad. In another
written to the monarchical couple after
he reached the new world, Columbus
mentions trying to raise an army for
quote the war and conquest of Jerusalem
unquote. That his voyage is centered on
liberating Jerusalem from Islam is
further evident in the title of one 2011
book, Columbus and the quest for
Jerusalem. Nor were Spain and Columbus
the first to implement the strategy.
Once Portugal was cleared of Islam as
early as 1249, its military orders
launched into Muslim Africa. According
to historian George Grant, the great and
overriding motivation behind Prince
Henry the Navigator's explosive energy
and expansive intellect was the simple
desire to take the cross, to carry the
crusading sword over to Africa, and thus
to open a new chapter in
Christrysendom's holy war against Islam.
Prince Henry launched all those
discovery voyages because he quote
sought to know if there were in those
parts any Christian princes who would
aid him against the enemies of the faith
wrote a contemporary. By the way, do all
these inconvenient facts behind the
founding of the new world make Columbus,
Ferdinand, Isabella, Prince Henry,
indeed the whole of Christendom
Islamophobes, as those few modern-day
critics who bother mentioning the true
motivation of Columbus's voyage allege.
For example, in an LA Times op-ed, Yale
historian Alan Mikyel or Mikyle wrote,
quote, "A primary force behind
Columbus's Atlantic crossings was a fear
and hatred of Islam. This shaped how
white Europeans engaged with the new
world and its native peoples for
centuries and how today's Americans
understand the world." Columbus was born
into Europe's anti-Islamic mindset in
1451.
While much of this is true, Mikyle does
not bother explaining why there was such
a fear and hatred of Islam or why Europe
had an anti-Islamic mindset in the first
place. Rather, white Europeans were just
unenlightened bigots, racists in
contemporary of infinitely overdone
parlance. But therein lay the irony.
Yes, Columbus and Europeans were
Islamophobes, but not in the way that
word is used today. While the Greek word
phobos has always meant fear, its usage
today implies irrational fear. However,
considering that for nearly a thousand
years before Columbus, Islam had
repeatedly attacked Christendom to the
point of swallowing up threequarters of
its original territory, including for
centuries Spain. That Islam's latest
iteration in the guise of the Ottoman
Turks was during Columbus' lifetime
devastating the Balkans and
Mediterranean, slaughtering and
enslaving any European who dare travel
east through their domains. And
considering that even centuries after
Columbus, Islam was still terrorizing
the West, marching into Vienna with
200,000 jihadists in 1683 and even
provoking America into its first war as
a nation around the year 1800. The very
suggestion that Western fears of Islam
were or are irrational is itself the
height of irrationalism.
At any rate and in short, let's not just
receelebrate Columbus Day, but let's
also remember and learn from the events
that gave rise to